[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages in the next half
hour then we'll see what's making the
headlines with the political editors of
the Daily Mirror and the Scottish Sun
John Stevens and Rachel Watson welcome
to both of you so as ever let's take a
first look at the front pages according
to the financial times NHS leaders have
said the safety of patients cannot be
guaranteed during tomorrow's ambulance
strikes those safety concerns are also
the main focus for the eye
the guardian Echoes the message of NHS
bosses imploring the prime minister to
enter negotiations while the telegraph
focuses on the health secretary Steve
Barkley's claim that unions are
consciously making a decision to inflict
harm on patients
the Metro offers a festive warning to
would-be ambulance users you'd better
watch out
the star says advice over what to do and
not to do tomorrow amounts to wrapping
the public in Cotton wool
Daily Mail attacks the strikes the
Striking workers rather asking how will
they live with themselves if people die
tomorrow
against the backdrop of the strikes the
mirror pictures the suspended Pier
baroness moan at a five-star hotel in
France she has denied any wrongdoing
over the awarding of PPE contracts
during the pandemic
well failed that is the headline for the
Daily Express as their investigation
finds only one of the 120 first-class
letters they posted arrived the next day
while a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers all you watch us
our guests and facts so let's head to
John Stevens and Rachel Watson and John
as we saw there it is definitely wrap
yourself up in Cotton wool day isn't it
yeah so a big day tomorrow there's gonna
be a lot of strikes in England I think
it is I guess nine out of ten ambulance
trusts in England can be impacted by
stroke action the only place that's not
gonna have any strikes at all is the
east of England Ambulance Service and
yeah it's gonna be a massive day there's
going to be obviously a lot of
disruption but I think there's big
questions for the health secretary Steve
Barkley about why on Earth is he not
doing anything it seems to stop these
strikes from happening he did meet some
of the unions today being refused to
talk about the one issue which we know
is the thing that is important to
sorting this out and that is pay and the
government don't seem willing to have
any sort of conversation on that so
we're stuck in this Deadlock
well the Daily Telegraph has an op-ed as
it's known in the trade from Steve
Barkley
um in which she says that NHS England
has contingency plans in place but they
can only go so far in limiting the
significant impact on patient safety
caused by the Union drive to cause
massive disruption to services and the
the telegraph headline there unions have
made a conscious choice to inflict harm
on patients I mean this does not sound
like
um a Meeting of Minds or a flexible
resolution to this conflict is it that
headline
thank you
Rachel
oh sorry I know I mean some of this
language where you look across the
papers it does feel quite inflammatory
and I think as John mentioned there the
refusal of Steve Martin to discuss hey
and this is how the strikes are going to
end this is how the government and the
unions are going to bring the strikes to
an end when they can reach an agreement
on this and what we seem to see very
little from the government is actually
compromised
um in Scotland we've had further talk
between Nicola sturgeon and the unions
up here we're waiting on the Royal
College of Nursing to find out
recent pay deal of 7.5 but in England
we're not seeing those discussions take
place and I think some of the language
you look at that op-ed in the Telegraph
and around language around the conscious
choice to inflict time on patients for
example you know the government has not
as as John said not making moves to end
this strike either they know how this
will end
and they know how to do it but they
don't seem to be willing to take those
actions to do it yes Ander the guardian
uh suggesting NHS leaders uh would like
the prime minister to intervene uh once
again talking
um about the dangers for people
um for example so Stephen Powers NHS
England's national medical director you
know talked about drinking sensibly uh
Don't Do extreme sports
um but the word being used there on the
front of the Guardian
um is attrition this attritional strike
action which you know could go on
possibly the uh the nurses Union
suggesting for six months
yeah we've had this war of words we've
had the government fleeing loads of muds
at the unions you saw it there in that
off pad written by Steve Barkley in the
telegraph but at the moment in the court
of public opinion the public are right
behind those striking nurses and the
Striking ambulance drivers I think there
was a poll by Hugo of today it showed
about 66 of people supported the nurses
and it was about half of that were
against them and it was similar figures
for ambulance drivers as well and yeah I
think people are really worried about
what is going to happen tomorrow but
they know on any other day of the year
at the moment if you do try and call an
ambulance it is really difficult and you
look at the response times if you have
something like a suspected heart attack
or a stroke in England there's a target
an ambulance should be able to respond
to within 18 minutes and the average in
November was 48 minutes so it's nowhere
near that so people yeah is going to be
big disruption tomorrow but if you need
an ambulance any day of the year at the
moment it is really hard to get hold of
one and that is my paramedics saying
they're having to take this drastic
action to get listened to because
there's clearly a massive problem here
that needs sorting out well the daily
mail
um you know making its views quite clear
here how will they live with themselves
if people die today uh Daily Mail
comment there as you can see it Beggars
belief in Britain today you could call
999 to seek help for a loved one who
suffered a heart attack or stroke with
no certainty an ambulance will arrive I
mean it is quite a state of play isn't
it Rachel
hmm
yeah I think so as John mentioned there
the the real public backing here seems
to be behind those who are going on
strike they understand what nurses and
ambulance workers are asking for you
know these are the people that look
after us in hospital when we need them
take us to hospital we've seen them work
throughout the pandemic we know how
difficult their job is we know how
increasingly difficult it is when you
read um stories across the papers from
ambulance drivers paramedic nurses
talking about those situations that
they're in every single day and that
they're asking
um for better conditions and a pay rise
and it's not you know it's something
that the public understands they they
rely on WE rely on these people in the
NHA
um and then but there does seem to be
this kind of effort and I'm not sure
that that's going to sway the Public's
mind to be honest when you look at um
some of the comments made particularly
if you look at those feedback the
comments or another paper has sources
close to Steve Berkeley I'm talking
about the strike action and the unions I
don't actually saying issues like this
will the way the Public's mind on where
the problems are as John said there are
you know it's not easy to get hold of an
ambulance any day of the year people
have to wait everybody has a story of
someone they know who's had problems
with taking NHS treatments to the
ambulances and they know that it's the
government who are responsible for the
policy who are responsible for the
decisions that go on behind the scenes
well it's interesting um just a bit of
comment on the front page of the
financial times which is another paper
that talks about health bosses unable to
guarantee patient safety
um suggesting there are real benefits
from resolving the disputes quickly a
pay rise agreed today is cheaper than
the same one agreed six strike-filled
months later and I think that has
resonance with some conservative MPS who
are beginning to question whether there
should be more flexibility from
government but if we look at the Ft
um the health bodies urging soon act to
open negotiations on pay sunak telling
MPS today any discussions on pay a
should be in the context of next year's
settlement which applies from April
2023 adding that he was wedded to the
current independent review body process
which we know he is now is there any
suggestion they could bring forward
those discussions on next year's pay
settlement make them generous and make
them
um come in earlier um John would that be
a solution to this do you think
I think potentially and I think the
health unions are up for some sort of
compromise I know the nurses started out
with their opening Gambit if they wanted
uh pay rise five percent of inflation
the government say that with about 19
but when you actually speak to the union
leaders they don't want these strikes to
go on forever they want them to come to
a conclusion they're Keen to find some
way of putting them to a stop whether
that's you give NHS staff some sort of
one-off bonus do you look at what you
could do next year as you say bringing
forward those types of discussions and
the only way you're going to find out
what could be a possible kind of way
forward is by getting around the table
and having those conversations I think
that's why there's a lot of frustration
from people including from Tory MPS that
the government don't seem to be up for
wanting that sort of conversation and
you're on the front page of the Ft there
you've got a letter it's a last minute
plea from the NHS Confederation today
writing to receive sunag and just saying
to him there are real risks here for
patients involved and we do need to find
some way out of this and trying to urge
him and the unions to get together and
to sort this out
yes sir Jeffrey Clifton Brown became the
latest story and Peter urged compromise
he talked about the need for flexibility
you know will the pressure grow do you
think to reach a resolution at least
with the NHS workers who are going on
straight Rachel
I think the pressure here is is going to
continue to grow and I think you know
that word compromise there has to be a
compromise this is how it is going to
end you know we might get to a point
where it's not what the government wants
and it's not what the unions want but
it's acceptable for both sides and I
think that's where it has to get to but
to do that you have to get around the
table and you have to be willing to have
those difficult discussions and talk
about pay and what can happen next we
all know these are difficult times for
governments too as I said in the
Scottish government had to move money
around in year take money from other
um budget other areas in government to
put a new offer of seven points five
percent to NHS workers in Scotland
that's been accepted by two young two
unions so far rejected by one but we're
waiting on them in the Royal College of
nurses to see whether they'll accept it
and put off their strikes indefinitely
and I think that it does take compromise
so we're going to get to a point where
this pressure becomes too much and the
government is going to have to back down
on the fact that it won't move Beyond
this four percent of whether that is
something like John was speaking about
um a one-off payment if you look at next
year and potentially what you could do
to benefit the the
um nurses and ambulance staff then but I
think you know there has to be
compromise here and I think tomorrow
will show that I think it will
you know this is this is very serious
and what happens tomorrow we'll show
people how serious um the situation is
going to get and how much worse it could
get if strikes to go on well the Daily
Star sums it all up nicely for Us
official government guide to surviving
the ambulance strike they say wrap
yourselves in Cotton wool Health
Minister don't do anything risky
ambulance Chief try hard not to fall
over and an NHS boss better lay off the
Sherry the festive chair part of that
yes good luck everybody getting through
tomorrow uh plenty more still to come in
the next part of our program Health
Service staff as you know not the only
people striking will turn our attention
to Industrial action by postal workers
when we come back
[Music]
well welcome back you are watching The
Press preview with me once again John
Stevens and Rachel Watson uh we've
talked about
um Health strikes Now we move on to mail
um Rachel let's take a look at the Daily
Express
um their first paragraph the true
shocking failure of Royal Mail to
deliver post on time is exposed today in
an Express investigation what did they
do
yeah so I'm we all know that there's a
Royal Mail strike they're about to go
out again postal workers on the 23rd and
24th
um but the express have decided to do
their own investigation into this and
see exactly what mail is making it when
so they sent 120 letters first class
um and found out that only one of those
arrived within with the next working day
they also sent 120 letters second class
and found out that 10 of those arrived
within two to three days so they've
tried to kind of you know show the
impact that the strikes are having on
the nation at the moment as we run up on
the run-up Christmas and those Christmas
cards that people are equally waiting on
yeah but did you see the next bit after
nearly two weeks more than half of our
first class and 64 of our second class
letters have still not arrived for
someone like me who's gonna go home and
write my Christmas cards overnight I
don't know why I'm bothering To Be
Honest John
well you'll be early for next Christmas
at this rate so that'd be fine just two
best of one stone but yeah I mean we
were saying in the break that I mean my
post has been so bad recently I mean
I've had hardly any Christmas cards at
all it either means that all my friends
the family have fallen out with me or
there is something drastically wrong
with posts and yeah I think people like
yourself posting your Christmas cards
now there's not much hope for you Anna
yeah I mean there's a lot of important
stuff in the mail too Beyond uh festive
greetings um just very quickly too I see
on the front of the telegraph um they
suggest that Mick Lynch from the rmt has
held secret talks with network rail
bosses amid hopes that he will sue for
peace in the new year as public for
train strikes crumbles
um well certainly there are a lot of rmt
and today we heard an aslef strike date
also announced for the first week in
January so
um you know that is absolutely critical
to Rachel just quickly
yeah I think the telegraph seemed to be
putting up positive spin on this the
suggestion that like Lynch might be able
to bring these strikes to an end the
fact that they are you know there have
been those discussions with um Network
real and providers so I think you know
maybe a little bit of positive news that
maybe an arpeggio can be agreed with
those union members at some point in the
the very near future yeah and certainly
people trying to get to Scotland uh from
the south east of England are having to
set off very early are they not on
Christmas Eve was the last train what
was it 8 AM or something I can't
remember now but um you know it's an
early start for strike day certainly or
was that on the 23rd oh I'm gonna flick
this up anyway
um moving on to uh another story on the
uh front pages and that is the
coronation which will restore the UK in
the eyes of the world I thought it was
going to be paired down is that not so
John
I think it gets me paired down in some
ways but the number 10 today was saying
that they think that there might
actually be a bigger number of foreign
dignitaries at the coronation compared
to the funeral because obviously we know
the funeral was at the last minute there
wasn't much time to prepare for it
because the dates in the diary now
months in advance for the coronation we
know it's is it the 6th of May around
then the 8th of May one of those days
but anyway they know what data is and so
different countries around the world are
going to prepare for it and that sounds
like is going to be an absolutely
massive Gathering of world leaders in
London okay John Stevens Richard Watson
thank you both very much indeed thank
you we'll see you later for more